okay hello it's an honor to be speaking
here yeah as Peter mentioned today's
talk is a joint talk with me and Nikhil
it's about it's sort of a survey on our
semester-long program in geometry of
polynomials what I'm going to talk about
is basically this method called the
polynomial paradigm and how to use it in
designing and studying algorithms and
other stuffs in physics and communities
so let me start by going back like 200
years ago so let's say you have a
univariate polynomial with real
coefficients all polynomials are
polynomials I'm going to talk about
today will have real coefficients so
let's say I have this polynomial P I can
look at its root in the complex plane
here are the roots I can also look at
the roots of the derivative of P and
here are the roots of the derivative of
P now Gauss asked this question that if
you look at the convex hull of the roots
of P it includes the roots of P prime
that the roots of the derivative of P so
this conjecture was proved by Lukas few
decades later and basically we can see
this as a history of this so the thing
is you can see here that there is
interplay between doing operations on a
polynomial and its roots okay so what
we're gonna see is generalizations of
this in many settings so you can involve
level extend this so let's say you have
a univariate polynomial you can look at
it in three ways one way is to look at
it as a sum writing the polynomial the
polynomial in terms of the coefficients
if I have a degree n polynomial I'm
gonna have n coefficient and n plus 1
coefficients I can look at it as a
product a degree n polynomial will have
n different roots so I can look at the
polynomial as products or I can look at
the polynomial just as a function which
Maps complex number to complex numbers
now I have this tree representation or
three ways of thinking about the
polynomial I can ask these questions
like what happens if I change one to the
other if I change coefficients what
happens with the rules or what happens
to the function and so on or you can ask
what happens and I differentiate if I
differentiate a function what happens to
the roots or the zeros so Gauss Lucas
theorem was like an example of such a
thing but in general we are interested
in multivariate versions of these
questions when you have multivariate
polynomials now it turns out that if you
have a multivariate polynomial in
general you cannot like it's not easy to
relate these questions or to answer
these questions but the main ingredients
that we're going to see a lot in this
talk is that when you have like
multivariate polynomials when they have
nice zero free region then you can argue
about coefficients roots or function
values so here I show you two example of
such a thing in the first example you
see a univariate real with a polynomial
where the roots are all real so there
are no roots in the upper half complex
plane in the not in the right you see
another example where we have a
bivariate polynomial where there are no
roots in the positive or set so here are
two simple examples but we're going to
see more interesting example as we go
into the talk so so what is the
polynomial power line it says that
assuming you have polynomials with nice
0 through regions you can relate
coefficients to function than 0 so you
can study the interplay between these
three objects so this was something that
mathematicians have been thinking about
for decades but what has happened
recently over say the last 15 years is
that there are many settings in which
you have say a mathematical object like
a combinatorial object or a probability
distribution and what you can do you you
you write a generating polynomial out of
that object then you study the
generating polynomial using this sort of
polynomial paradigm you prove theorems
or arguments about the generating
polynomial and then you pull back that
that statements to to study their
corresponding probability distribution
so the thesis we want a sort of propose
here is that you know whenever you you
have a discrete object you want to study
its global properties one way you can do
it is that you can encode your object
into a polynomial which has nice zing of
regions use tools from here and then
maybe that gives you a way to study
global properties of your object okay so
let me put this in context we're going
to talk about four applications today so
I'm going to talk about the first two
and the kill we'll talk about the second
than the last two so in all these
applications we're dealing with some
polynomial with a nice zero free region
in the first application we see the
interaction between the polynomials and
probability distributions we see that
assuming you have nice zero flow regions
there are some closure properties for
the polynomials so we will be in in this
case with so-called real estate
polynomials that will give you some nice
class of property distributions and you
will see how you can use that to study
traveling salesman problem as an
application in a second application in a
second example we'll see a different
class of polynomials which are not
concave in in certain parts of the R to
the N we can use that to study spectral
gap of random walks and then we'll see
as application that you can study
counting problems for matrix and Nikhil
will talk about the cat assessing your
problem applications to statistical
physics ok so let me start with the
first one so ok so again what do I want
to talk about I want to talk about how
you can relate polynomials to
probabilities and use that to study
probability distributions so let me
start with some very simple setting so
let's say this is Berkeley it's going to
rain tomorrow at probability p1 it's
going to rain the day after tomorrow
with probability P 2 you can write a
generating polynomial for each of these
events Z 1 P 1 plus 1 minus P 1 this is
the generating polynomial for this this
is the Z 2 P 2 plus 1 minus P 2 is the
journey polynomial for the other one so
basically each of these events or you
can think of it as so called the
Bernoulli random variable happens the
probability 1 so we have two
distributions I can study the joint yes
the generating polynomial I'm not going
to define formally but it's basically
you look at every set in your
distribution you look at the generate
the generating monomial for that set the
product of the eyes for the set times
the probability of that set okay we
don't see example
go forward so good so now that you have
two you have two different polynomials
you can you can study the joint
distribution of these two random
variables by by treating them as
independent random variables so I can
study the Joint Distribution by taking
the product of these two polynomials
that I just showed you so for example
this would say that the probability that
it rains today and tomorrow is p-1 times
p-2
okay okay so you have this now let's see
how can I generalize this to end let's
say you have n independent Bernoulli's
v1 up to BN you can similarly multiply
they're generating polynomial you get
such a polynomial and and it turns out
that this is a real rooted polynomial
because each of the terms here is a
linear polynomial with a real root so I
get the product is also real good now
the nice fact is that the converse of
this is also true if you have a
univariate polynomial with this which is
real rooted and has non-negative
coefficients then there exist
independent Bernoulli random variables
such that their sum is distributed
according to the coefficients the
probability that the sum is equal to K
is exactly a cait over the sum of the
coefficients okay so in particular it
turns out that the the the prior of the
pi4 the BI for the eyes Bernoulli is a
function of the eye fruit of the
polynomial now what you see here is an
example of a correspondence between
probabilities and polynomials whenever
you have real rooted polynomial
correspond to Bernoulli's and
independent Bernoulli's and Sol and
unwise the versa now you can ask okay
enough about Bernoulli's Bernoulli's are
like these are independent we know
everything about independent
distributions can we go beyond
independence so let me show you how we
can use multivariate polynomials to go
beyond independence so I want to talk
about random spanning three
distributions let's say we have this
graph if we remind you that the spanning
tree is a sub graph which is connected
and it has no cycles so here the graph I
show you has four different spanning
trees by removing different edges you
get these four spanning trees you can
study a uniform size distribution on
spanning trees so I pick each of the
probability 1/4 let's say I enable the
edges as follows like 1 2 3 4 5 now you
can write down the generating polynomial
of each spanning tree by taking a
monomial corresponding to the to the
edges that appear in that spanning tree
so here I'm going to have Z 1 times Z 2
times the 3 times Z 5 and I'm going to
multiply the 1 by 1/4 because the
probability of choosing this tree is 1/4
you sum them over that's a generating
polynomial of a random spanning tree
distribution ok good so so now we know
how to go from this to polynomial now
let's now let's study the operations you
can do on probability distributions and
see what they correspond to in the
polynomial language so I start with a
simple operation called projection so so
what is projection it's like to use
zooming you you let's say i zoom in on
the edges adjacent to D and I forget I
ignore the rest of the edges okay I just
want to see what is the projection of my
distribution and the edges adjacent to D
so what this corresponds to in the
polynomial language if you think about
it it's nothing but substituting 1 for
the edges not for the edges that are
ignore for the edges that I don't zoom
into okay so just substitute with one
and you get this problem is that
something one for z1 and z2 and you get
a generating polynomial of the projected
distribution so here is one operation
let me tell you another operation let's
say now you want to study the grid the
rank sequence so called in province
tribution which is in this case would be
the degree distribution of d what is the
distribution of me that's the
probability that is equal to 2 or it is
equal to 3 so what do I really want I
really want to look at this polynomial I
don't want to treat this as different
variables I just I just care if like two
edges or three edges or four edges
adjacent to this sample so what that
really means is that I really want to
symmetrize it I just want to treat all
variables the same and I just want to
look at the power of that variable okay
so this operation is costing
metallization it gives me this
polynomial and what does this tell me
this tells me that the probability that
a degree of this vertex B is equal to
two is equal to one-half the coefficient
of x squared the probably x3 is equal to
one-half as well okay so
good so now you can you can write this
long table there are many more things
that have a written of correspondence
between probability distributions and
polynomials projection corresponds to
substitution rank sequence correspond to
symmetrization conditioning correspond
to differentiation I didn't talk about
correlation corresponds to entries of
the Hessian of the log of the polynomial
and so on now the point is that let's
say I want to study probability
distribution suppose I have a class of
polynomial which are closed under the
operations in the right hand side then I
would get a nice class of probability
distributions which are closed under the
operations in the ref in the left hand
side okay so so that's what I'm going to
do next I'm going to define a class of
polynomial which are closed on the right
and that would give me a nice family of
probability distributions okay so let's
go to that so this is the first class of
polynomials we're going to see so we say
so i wanna be--fine so-called real
estate or polynomial so let's say you
have a polynomial P again with real
coefficients now one thing to remember
is that when when you have multivariate
polynomials then the roots are not as I
say are not or no longer distinct there
would be a continuous there will be
continuously many roots so in
particularly if you have a degree two
polynomial like this you can look at its
roots for example in R squared and then
you would get curves if you have a
degree three polynomial like this you
can look at its root in our cube and you
get like surfaces and so on we say a
polynomial which is of degree B is real
stable if every line pointing to the
positive or cent cuts these roots are
exactly D points okay so here you see
that every line pointing this way cuts
exactly the set of roots at exactly two
points similarly that's a degree three
polynomial every line pointing to the
positive words and cuts these set of
roots and exactly three points so that's
called real stable now they're real the
real zero free region of this polynomial
you should think of it as a part of C to
the N but I don't want to get into that
it turns out that a polynomial is really
stable if and only if it has no
in the upper half complex plane okay so
roughly speaking having no roots in the
upper half complex plane corresponds
like having like regions with no roots
in the complex plane corresponds to like
intersection number of the lines in r2
or r3 or Rd okay so that's really what
is going on that's really been nice zero
for region for these polynomials now now
that we have this polynomial let's study
their properties so here are some simple
properties
first of all any univariate real estate
polynomial is real rooted second of all
if you have a real state polynomial it
is closed under many operations such as
substitution differentiation or
symmetrization and one thing important
to us is that random spanning tree
distributions are real stable okay so
the proof of these statements are not
complicated that for example the one the
closure for differentiation just follows
from the Gauss Lucas theorem I told you
at the beginning many other proofs are
just calculus or some limiting argument
so they're not so complicated but let's
see what we can get out of it
okay so let me let me show you an
example two random spanning trees so
here is a simple lemma you can prove it
what I just told you let's say you have
a random spanning tree distribution and
you have a vertex v such that the
expected degree of V is somewhere
between 1.5 and 2.5 then I want to prove
that the probability that a degree of V
is 2 is at least 1/8 is that is the
constant bounded away from 0 so there's
nothing special about 1.5 and 2.5 as
long as this is more than 1 and this is
less than 2 you get a constant here okay
so let's see how we can study such a
question so let's start from the you
know random spanning tree polynomial for
this graph let's say so we said that ran
the spanning tree polynomials are real
root as I said earlier stable so you get
the real state polynomial now I want to
zoom into the degree of D let's say so I
first do projection I substitute 1 for
every edge which is not the neighbor of
my vertex so I get this polynomial which
is also real estate because of close
around there substitution then because I
just want to look at it the degree
distribution the rank the degree
distribution I just see much
I just count how many edges neighbor of
VR sample so I get a univariate
polynomial like this where coefficients
describe the probability distribution
now
this polynomial is really stable but we
say that any real stable univariate
polynomial is real loose so this is a
real luther's polynomial and now you can
use the fact that for real without that
real rooted polynomials are just some of
independent Bernoulli so there are there
are independent variables V 1 up to B 3
such that the sum has the same
distribution as a degree of my vertex so
what does this say this says that event
no random spanning two distributions are
not uniform a lot they are not
independent there are correlation
between the edges using this machinery
you can turn your question into a
question about sum of independent
Bernoulli random variables and now you
know you can use a lot of tools
developed in in probability theory to
study such a question okay good so now
we can ask you can add okay who cares
about like spanning trees with degree
two okay why is this interesting it
turns out that it's interesting because
of travelling says my problem so let me
just very briefly remind you what it is
so in travelling salicylate let's say
you go to San Francisco for the first
time you want to visit some places and
you want to take the shortest tour so
maybe here maybe this this is the
shortest tour that visits over beverages
all of the places that you see so it's
really a Hamiltonian cycle now if you
think about it what is the Hamiltonian
cycle it's really a spanning tree where
every vertex has degree 2 I mean it's
really a spanning tree like plus an edge
where everybody has degree 2 so we
should be interested in spanning trees
where you have many degree 2 vertices so
now we seem to getting somewhere so so
you can so basically you can formulate
an argument starting from a TSP instance
you can use tools from convex
optimization to construct a random
spanning tree distribution where they
expect the degree of every vertex is
equal to 2 then you can use the lemma I
just mentioned to say that ok whenever
you have expectation to the probability
is equal to 2 you know with at least a
constant problem their degree is equal
to V that is a constant probability so
you get that the constant faction of
vertices will have degree equal to 2 so
for example here
our two examples in the left this is a
tourist graph on like about 25 vertices
that and the vertices with degree two
are colored in red as you see a constant
fraction of vertices have degree 2 and
here I'm doing the same thing for a
complete graph again I'm choosing a
random spanning tree of a complete graph
where they expected degree of every
vertex is 2 and again you see a constant
fraction of vertices have degree exactly
equal to 2 so so the point is yeah the
point is using this machinery you can
prove that whenever you sample from such
a random spanning tree distribution you
have a lot of like maybe 1 30% 40% of
the edges of the vertices will have
degree equal to 2 now this part is not
so trivial but it turns out that this
helps you to the the fact that you have
many degree 2 vertices helps you to tell
to say that you can augment a tree into
a tsp to of a small cost ok so so this
all comes down to this theorem we proved
so like a few years ago that improve the
crystal field so let me give you the
context so the thing is there is this
simple algorithm by Christofias back in
1976 which gives a 3 half approximation
for TSP and so long standing open
problem to improve it what we did with
Siberians thing was that we improve the
crystal fields algorithm like by epsilon
by constant epsilon for a special case
of tsp called graphic TSP and that's
exactly the way we do it there are many
other follow-up works that I'm not
covering here but basically the point is
we can use polynomials to study
algorithms okay so okay so so far I
covered the first thing so I said that
how you can use closure properties of
polynomials with nice 0 through region
to talk about the structure of
probability distributions and we use
that an application for TSP so in this
case then nice 0 free region was the
upper half complex plane now let me go
over the second application which is how
to use la concave polynomials to study
matrix ok so let me first tell you what
mate roots are and then tell you how
polynomials are related to them so
matrix are this are these abstract sort
of objects they they are defined to
generalize notion of linear independence
you get four vectors so let's say let's
say you have a set of vectors in a
finite
in any field it could be fine out or
real or complex field we say a set I of
these vectors are independent if the
corresponding vectors are linearly
independent so for example if you look
at this picture the vector is 3 and 5
are linearly independent so this is the
independent set but 4 & 5 are not are
dependent because they point to the same
direction so this is not independence so
this is set of independent sets bases
are maximal independent sets so here we
have five bases one is orthogonal to
everybody else so it's in all of the
bases but the rest of them okay we get 1
2 3 1 2 4 and so on so you get 5 bases
match with our basically sort of
invented about 78 years ago to to sort
of generalize many many things we see
like many of the objects we see in in
combinatorics and now we see all we see
also in computer science
like spanning trees matchings linearly
independent vectors and so on let me
tell you one application of study images
and then tell you what we do
so here is one application of using
matrix in an application in encoding
theory so let's say Alice Juana sends a
message to Bob she's gonna call it what
our set of feasible codes and you can
think of them as follows there is a
parity check matrix M I'm the set of
feasible codes are exactly the kernel of
M it's a set of vectors X such that M of
X is equal to 0 so Alice want to send
this message to Bob now suppose this
channel is noisy every bit will be
dropped with some probability P
independently okay so here for example
the first and the third bits are flip
are dropped what you want to see is that
what is the probability that we can
recover the message that we can recover
the code you know assuming everybody's
dropped probably P independent so if you
think about it it turns out that you can
recover the code if and only if the
columns corresponding to the remove bits
are linearly independent so so so in
order to compute the recovery the
recover probability all you need to do
is the
count the number of linearly independent
set of columns or in other words if you
look at the corresponding make sure it's
the number of independent sets in that
matrix okay so now we see there are some
applications for doing counting problems
on measure for example but there are
many other applications I'm not going to
cover so let me tell you a little bit of
history Edmonds
study like optimization of our matrix in
70s he defined this object called
matriot which is the convex hull of the
indicator vector of the basis of the
major so here my mate show it has five
bases I'm looking at the indicator
vectors of them for example 1 1 1 0 0
corresponds to the base 1 2 3 ok so you
get this you can look at the convex hull
of things in general we kind of
exponentially many bases in the number
in n in the number of elements so you
can have exponentially many vertices
faces and so on
but it turns out that even though this
poly tope is big you can you can do
optimization you can for example test if
a point is inside or outside this poly
tope and you can optimize convex
function over this pollito so so these
are the contribution of matrix office
re-add modes now Mihiel and mesh here
ask in 1989 whether you kind of study
random walks on these major based
polytopes so so what is that let's say
let's say this is the major base
polytope so see the edges here
correspond to swapping elements like the
edge between these two correspond to
swapping the element 2 and 3 so if you
give me a base I can easily figure out
its neighbors in this major in base
pollito so you can just treat this poly
tope adjust the graph let's say I start
from here from this this vertex I can I
can run a random walk each time from a
vertex I can go to one of its neighbors
ok and so on and so forth ok so I can
run this random walk and then you know
if you do a so called the metropolitan
filter you can just run it such that it
converges to a uniform distribution and
the question is does this converge
rapidly to the uniform distribution or
not if it does it it allows you to
sample basis from MHO it and do counting
problems for me ok so so here is what we
proved
with Inari quick wheeze here somewhere
okay Leo and Cynthia wins on that
basically for any major if you look at
the Markov chain and vertices of the
Metroid base pollito it converges
rapidly to the uniform distribution like
a time N squared or even less if the
rank of the matrix smaller so yeah
basically we managed to answer this
question of Mihiel and mozzie Ronnie
after some number of years the main the
main tool that we use for this or let me
say let me say one thing so I haven't
said what it means to converge to the
uniform distribution let me be imprecise
here instead I'm going to show you a
simulation so what is the simulation I'm
showing two graphs on the left you see
the graph of a sort of a cycle and like
80 vertices on the right you see the
graph of a major base polytope for some
matron that distribution is color-coded
here so if two vertices have sort of
similar color you it means that they
have a similar value in a distribution
and the point is if you see the graph on
the right side you got to the same color
at like seven steps in the left even at
like 13 steps you don't get to the same
color basically the point is even though
the graph our matrix can be
exponentially big in the number of
elements it will converge to the uniform
distribution in time logarithmic in the
number of its vertices whereas for a
cycle for example it can take it takes
time like polynomial in the number of
vertices so if you are exponentially
many it would take exponential time to
converge to the today's stationary
distribution the uniform distribution
okay so I want that I won't have time to
tell you about much about the proofs I
just want to say how the polynomials are
useful now here is how they are useful I
told you the spanning tree polynomial
before it turns out that the spanning
three polynomial corresponds to a
determinant polynomial of sum of
positive semi definite matrices that's a
well-known fact now there's a
fundamental facts in optimization that's
whenever you look at
determinants of some of PSD matrices the
log of that function is a concave
function so log of determinant is a
convex function what we proved is that
okay make sure is generalize the
spanning trees so in that in a similar
sense if you look at a generating
polynomial of a major as opposed to
generate a polynomial of a star
so what the generated eponymous made so
it just just sum over all of the bases
the product of the eyes in the base if
you look at the generating polynomial of
the matrix lock and came over the over
than positive or so so you just
generalize this fact in optimization and
again here the zero free region
corresponds to the positive order you
won't have any roots in the positive or
fair or time in fact the log of your
function would be concave in the
positive one okay I'm going to stop here
and it to make you okay I'll take that
as a hello clapping for me as well okay
so so I'm gonna continue the story that
Shannon started telling so let's just
recall I mean there hasn't been so long
what he said he he showed that we can
understand some rather complicated
probability distributions like the
distribution and spanning trees or graph
or distribution on basis of a Metroid by
encoding these exponentially size
distribution as coefficients of some
multivariate polynomial then observing
that these multivariate polynomials
they're not just some arbitrary
polynomials they have some nice big
structured 0 three regions and using
this fact to you know go between the
coefficients zeroes and other properties
the polynomials to answer these
questions so what I'm gonna do in the
rest of the talk is I'm gonna build on
this a little more I'm going to explore
a different way in which you can use
polynomials to do common networks so I'm
going to do is I'm gonna show you some
some instances where you can encode very
interesting combinatorial information
directly in the zeros of a polynomial as
opposed to the coefficients so that's
one difference from what Cheyenne talked
about he was always encoding things as
coefficients of a polynomial and you
know now we're really going to start
caring about what the values of these
zeros are so you can view my part of the
talk is sort of more quantitative
version of what chanted I'm going to fit
in two applications
one is something I call the graphed
skeleton problem which essentially
reduces to a problem and about
controlling eigenvalues of some random
matrices I'm going to show how this can
be you know understood by it actually
throwing away a bunch of information and
turning with matrices into polynomials
and exploiting the interplay between the
coefficients and zeros of these
polynomials and this is the longer story
and then finally I'm going to briefly
discuss sort of long you know going
research program in statistical physics
about approximating partition functions
of certain statistical physics models
and again the broad theme is the same
there's these polynomials are going to
have some zero free regions which are
now going to have maybe a little more
complicated structure than before and
this is going to allow us to move freely
between coefficients and roots and
exploit some surprising phenomena there
okay so what's the graph skeleton
problem okay so here's a here's a sort
of motivation for this problem so this
is a map of the power network of
California apparently from ca.gov
and okay here's a you know unfortunate
situation they could write suppose there
is a budget cut and you can only keep
half of the power lines for some reason
okay so you have to delete half of the
power lines but you get to choose which
half you want it to be and so well what
would you want to do you'd want to you
know somehow delete the ones that are
redundant and you'd want to keep half of
the half of the lines which preserve
half of the functionality so what you'd
like to do is you know can you do this
in a way which preserves half of the
functionality of the electrical network
and one reasonable way to make that
mathematically precise is to say that
well this is you can I mean okay I don't
know how reasonable it is but you can
think of this as being a resistive
circuit and then the question is is
there a way to choose half of the links
such that whenever you put a potential
difference across the edges of the
network the energy dissipated in the
subset that you chose is about half of
whatever it was originally okay that's
one way of phrasing this or maybe you
know maybe you don't care about
electricity maybe you're interested in
Road so that's a map of the highways and
in California and suppose you could only
keep half the roads again could you
could you choose
subset that retains half the
functionality here the appropriate
definition of functionality is that for
every cut so that means for every subset
of terminals in this road network if you
look at the boundary of that subset if
you look at the roads leaving that
subset the weight should be about half
of what it is in the original graph okay
so this is this is some problem which
which could or hopefully not in the near
future arise and and and what I'm going
to show you is a mathematical problem
which includes both of these especial
cases this is what I'm gonna call the
graph skeleton problem so I have a graph
G so to define the problem I need to
define the notion of energy on a graph
so the energy of a vector of potentials
on a graph is simply the sum of squared
differences of the values of the
potentials across the edges so here is a
graph G it has some number of vertices
this is a these red numbers or our
potentials on the vertices and so then
the energy is just its sum of squared
differences across the edges so this
contributes 1 this contributes 1 this
contributes to you add up you add them
all up you get some real number and this
is this is the same as the usual
physical notion of energy in spring and
resistor networks so this is the graph
skeleton problem so suppose so the input
is a graph G finite unweighted
undirected graph and what I would like
to find is a sub graph of this graph so
that that's an edge sub graph so same
set of vertices but different edges as
shown in this picture so the Green said
is a sub graph of the original graph and
I would like you to have the property
that for all potentials X ok the energy
in the in the sub graph is between 40
and 60% of the energy and the original
ok so this is the ratio of these
energies is bounded between two numbers
that are close to 1/2 0.4 0.6 and you
know the tricky part is that one this
happens for all X simultaneously so for
all possible you know electrical loads
and of course there's nothing special
about 0.4 0.6 I could replace these by
any numbers 1 minus Q and Q and this
number Q measures how good a skeleton
this is so a graph that has this
property I'm going to call it a skeleton
and the skeleton is going to come with
the parameter Q and let Q so that Q of s
be the smallest
you so that this is true okay so so if Q
is one that's horrible because every sub
graph of a graph you know clearly
carries between zero and 100% of the
energy of the graph if Q is a half then
that's optimal that means i exactly
split it 50% and anything less than 1
minus epsilon is good if epsilon is some
constant that doesn't depend on anything
else and I'm gonna consider that a non
trivial skeleton of this graph I split
the graph into two pieces that aren't
sometimes functionally into one piece
that's functionally equivalent to the
whole okay so the question I want to
look at is does every graph have a good
skeleton any questions about the
statement of the the definition of the
problem okay so why would you want to do
this a bunch of reasons so first is this
electrical motivation maybe we're
interested in finding sports
approximations of electrical networks it
turns out this condition also implies
the the condition that came in the road
network problem so if I have a graph S
which is a skeleton of a graph G then it
turns out that for every cut C so C is
just a subset of the vertices the weight
of edges crossing the cut in s is about
half of the weight causing or Q if Q is
the quality of the skeleton there are
algorithmic motivations so it turns out
if you can do this you can use this to
solve an asymmetric inversion of the
Traveling Salesman problem this is work
you're an RN of a square and finally
this looks like a very common toriel
problem but it's very close to a problem
mathematical physics called the Caterson
singer problem which grew out of work of
Dirac and one women and I want to find
it here but it's it's some linear
algebraic problem that's very close to
this and it turns out if you can solve
this graph skeleton problem it's pretty
close to solving this other problem but
but that's the problem and so we're
interested in the question is every good
does every graph have such a skeleton so
let's look at some examples so here's
here's the easiest example it's parallel
paths so it's four parallel paths of on
six vertices and it's sort of it's quite
trivial to find the skeleton of this
graph right so for every edge there are
four copies let's just take the skeleton
to be two copies of each edge
you know clearly I mean it's easy to
check this the energy function for this
graph is literally half of what it is
for the original graph that's easy there
is one thing that's interesting about
this parallel path example which is if
you try to choose the skeleton randomly
it doesn't work so here's a here's a
random sub graph and this is this is not
a good skeleton at all and you can see
that by so you can see that by looking
at it for example this cut is completely
saturated and that's not good right it's
supposed to carry about half the weight
of the cut this cut is completely empty
so so in fact you can prove that a
random sub graph is it's not a good
skeleton it's a poor skeleton it has Q
equal to one with high probability so
even though it's easier to find a good
skeleton here they're they're actually
quite rare they can be exponentially
rare for example okay here's a slightly
more interesting example a dense random
graph so this is that's this is a graph
in which every node is included with
some constant probability so next it's
connected to an on average constant
fraction of the other nodes and here
it's not so clear how to choose your
skeleton s sorry if I forced you to try
to find a deterministic algorithm it's
not at all clear I mean it's not at all
clear to me what to do but here the
opposite thing works it turns out if you
choose a random sub graph so just just
include each edge with probability 1/2
in this sub graph s then you can prove
using concentration arguments so
essentially if you look at any cut so
let's say you look at this cut well you
know then the edges in this cut that are
included in s that sum of independent
random variables it's very concentrated
and this is good enough to prove that
actually you get this energy
preservation property and a random sub
graph is actually a it's a good skeleton
of a random graph ok so this is easy but
for a completely different reason from
the from the path example and now let's
look at a heart example it's a sparse
graph ok so that this is a graph in
which every vertex is connected to a
constant number of other vertices so
here the degree is 4 and again the goal
is to define the skeleton again it's not
clear what to do deterministically I
mean
you can try all sorts of clever things
this is quite a symmetric graph and
maybe you might be able to come up with
something but random certainly doesn't
work so for example here I've chosen a
random sub graph of this graph okay
can anyone see why this is a poor
skeleton it has an empty card yeah so so
it s is two connected components so
certainly it's it's a horrible you know
it's it's not it has Q equals one for
this reason okay you can choose another
random sub graph this one's connected
but now this one is bad for another more
complicated reason it turns out there's
some electrical flow where this sub
graph carries 100 percent of the energy
so this random one doesn't work either
you can keep going and you go for a
while and you won't find anything
because you can prove that with high
probability if you choose a random sub
graph of large constant D graph you're
gonna get something that's a bad
skeleton it's gonna have Q close to one
okay so it's not even clear whether a
skeleton exists for this graph and
finally since we're getting to harder
and harder examples here is an
impossible example so this is a dumbbell
graph this is two clicks
joined by a single edge it's quite easy
to see that this does not have a
non-trivial skeleton because of this
middle edge so if you put that in S
you're gonna have 100% if you don't you
have zero percent you're never gonna get
it close to us so this actually answers
the question it's not always possible
there are some graphs for which there is
no sparse there is no good skeleton and
the theorem IO whose proof I wanna
discuss is this theorem that we proved
marking on Spielman which said that if G
is a bridgeless graph okay so what the
theorem says is that that's the only
obstruction so if you give me a graph
that does not have a bridge edge there's
a quantitative definition of bridgeless
in terms of effective resistances I
won't get into it now because I want to
focus on the polynomial aspect so if G
is a bridgeless graph then it has a good
Scout in particular if it doesn't have
these bridge edges then you can find
some subset so that you get a you know Q
equals 0.6 coatis curve
okay now this is where polynomials come
in so I'm gonna explain the proof and it
uses this polynomial paradigm so the
first step of the proof is to encode all
sub graphs of a graph as polynomials and
in a way so that the quality of a sub
graph whether or not it's good skeleton
shows up as being one of the zeros of
this polynomial
okay so we're we turned this into a
problem about you know energy and things
like this in a problem about polynomials
with certain zeros and then even though
we're interested in the zeros we're
gonna average the polynomials
coefficient wise this is where this
interplay between coefficients and zeros
comes in and it's sort of surprising way
and this coefficient wise average even
though we know a random you know a
random sub graph is not a good skeleton
this is actually going to somehow allow
us to deduce the existence for good it's
golden okay so let's start encoding so
this is this is this is not very hard so
let's to go back to our problem because
the problem about preserving this energy
functional right so II G of X is
summation X I minus XJ squared well
that's a quadratic form which means it's
certainly you know X transpose L X for
some matrix L which it turns out to be
the graph laplacian it looks like
everybody in this room already knows
what that is but anyway I prepared this
for general audience but it doesn't
matter what it is its sub-matrix okay so
the energy is a quadratic form of some
matrix the condition were interested in
is finding an S so that the energy of s
is sandwiched between these two copies
of the energy of G now the point is
since is a quadratic form of a matrix
this is equivalent to an eigenvalue
problem so by representing this as
matrices using the quran fisher theorem
this condition is actually equivalent to
the property that the eigenvalues of the
passion of mass times the inverse of a
positive g are contained in Centreville
1 minus QQ ok basic linear algebra ok
now that that is a problem that is a
property of a polynomial right that's
just the same as saying the
characteristic polynomial of this matrix
how SLG inverse has all of its zeros in
this interval I'm not doing anything
fancy it's still basic linear algebra
and then now I want you know this is
some information about the lower and
upper bound on the zeros
I can just multiply this polynomial by
by the characteristic overview of the
complement of s and get a one-sided
condition okay so the characteristic
polynomial corresponding to s has zeros
lower bounded by 1 minus Q and upper
bounded by Q if this new polynomial PS
which is the product of the
characteristic polynomial the
characteristic of a complement has zeros
bounded upper bounded by 1 over Q okay
so that's that's it so now I've reduced
this to a problem about polynomials
given a graph I want to find a subset s
such that the corresponding polynomial
has largest root bound by Q ok so so the
idea now is to consider a random
polynomials and average them okay so
let's let's see how this looks so this
is our first example the path the
parallel paths this is the MP sub graph
and it's characteristic polynomial just
X I'm sorry it corresponding polynomial
is X to the 2n and all the roots are 0
so this circle is this these circles are
the zeros and this is the function okay
here is another another here's a random
partition doesn't look too good right
and I plotted the corresponding
polynomial in the same plot so this is
now this yellow polynomial and it has
zeros you know elsewhere it has a 0 0
but also has a 0 1 corresponding to
these bad cuts that's but it doesn't
look like a good polynomial either
remember we wanted a polynomial like
this with all zeros bounded away from 1
okay let's look at another one let's
let's plot it on the same graph and now
you see that you know you see that as
functions these kids these things can
have very different signs at any at any
given value of x right let's do it again
and so the zeros have a very clear
meaning it's not as clear what what what
you know what the function itself is
representing but I can just go on
plotting like this I do is a bunch of
times so these are now the polynomials
corresponding to a bunch of different
random sub graph
and what you see if you do this for a
while is that they're going to be lots
of cancellations right like this is huge
at this point this is small etc etc and
if you keep doing this for a while if
you just literally average everything
that you see you get something that
looks like this okay so this is this is
sort of the punchline that you had all
these crazy polynomials that were
blowing up all over the place some of
them had horrible roots most of them had
roots that were close to 1 and 0 but
when you average them all the stuff with
the bad route seems to cancel out and
you get a polynomial that looks like
this in fact the roots of this
polynomial are bounded I think between
like point point three and point seven
or something like okay so we did this
like after doing this in coding we did
this brainless thing we just average all
the polynomials over all partitions and
we got a polynomial that looks good but
it doesn't correspond to a partition
okay but you might argue the well this
is a very symmetric example you know
maybe there's so much symmetry there you
get these nice cancellations but now
let's run this on our hard graph right
this is our sparse graph that we were
having trouble with this is the
polynomial corresponding to this
partition okay it's something all these
polynomials are morning so they go to
infinity after one and so on but for
another partition okay another partition
and now this last so the first two I
plotted were both bad they both had
roots at 0 and 1 but the last one I
plotted is actually good you can you can
compute its roots and they're actually
bounded away from 0 and 1 0 point 9 and
point 1 or something like that this
particular one
now the magical thing that happens is if
you compute the average over all
possible partitions of this you get a
polynomial that looks like that ok I had
some technical issues that I couldn't
compute it in time because they're
they're two to the I don't know third
some large number of partitions of this
I couldn't compute them all time but I
know but I know that you get something
like this ok so again you have this
phenomenon that the he explained in a
moment I'll explain why I know again you
get this phenomenon and they're all the
other polynomials with large and small
zeros cancel out ok so so there's this
too surprising for all you're adding up
all these polynomials first of all
you're adding up a bunch of real rooted
power
you're always getting something with
real roots that should already be
surprising and the second surprising
thing is that not only are you getting
someone to grill with real roots all the
stuff you don't want is somehow
cancelling out and we can turn this into
a proof so here's one lemma for any
graph G the expected polynomial has real
roots and if the graph is visually
bridgeless the largest root is bounded
by 0.6 okay so this theorem articulates
this problem that these bad poems cancel
out we won't have time to say much about
the proof but it uses a lot of what
Cheyenne was talking about the idea is
to view the expected polynomial which is
the univariate polynomial as a
restriction of a certain multivariate
polynomial which is real stable which
has a nice 0 through region and then
analyze log Q inside this multivariate
zero free region ok so the zero few
reason now is more interesting it some
other convex cone but it's the same same
sort of theme ok so that proves that
when you average these polynomials it
somehow finds finds a good one and then
there's another lemma which I also won't
prove which says that well once you find
this good polynomial there's some
topological reason why there has to
exist a specific power Romeo a specific
graph which has its roots upper bounded
by the root to the average power so the
interesting thing here is the
expectations inside the largest root
operation anyway if you combine these
you get the serum and the the punchline
is that somehow you're interested in the
zeros you know that the average zeroes
are actually bad right I showed you that
but if you average the coefficient you
get these cancellations and somehow this
even though this is an average like
statistical object it finds these
polynomials that have good zeros and
their various open directions of our
understanding the center of the random
matrix here we still don't understand it
we know how to prove it we don't know we
don't personally understand every well
ok so that was one story the other story
which ok I don't have much time to talk
about in a minute on it
is is an old story from statistical
physics and I want to include it because
of its historical significance and also
because it connects you know many
different strands of research so this is
something about the ferromagnetic easing
model so if you don't know what the
ferromagnetic easing model is it's
probably hard for it's probably well I
don't know how much how well I can
explain it in in the next couple of
minutes but I'll try it so a caricature
of it is the following so it's a
probability distribution on subsets of a
graph so you have a given graph G such
as this graph here you have all
configure a you have you have a set of
configurations which is set of subsets
of the vertices of this graph then you
have a probability distribution that's
parameterize like two parameters beta
and lambda so beta is an interaction
parameter and okay and the probability
distribution is that the probability of
a set is proportional to beta raised to
the size of the boundary times lambda
raised to the size of the set okay so
what does this mean so so here's here's
here's a particular configuration so
what this means it's the probability
distribution favors configurations with
small boundary because beta is less than
1 and depending on what lambda is favors
configurations that either have many
vertices or few Birds okay so this is a
particular type of probability
distribution on the graph
here's another configuration it's gonna
have a probably a lower probability at
least if you in terms of beta because it
has a much larger boundary now the the
normalizing constant is probability
distribution is a polynomial if you add
all these things up you get a polynomial
which is called Z of Z the partition
function and it turns out that
derivatives of the log of this
polynomial again the same type of object
correspond to physical observables I
won't say any more about that and
therefore physicists are interested in
the location of the zero is because
existence of zeros implies a phase
transition in the physical and the
statistical physics model so the first
theorem in this line of work and really
one of the one of the like prototype
type theorems in this area is the
theorem of we and Yang and what they
proved is that in this model when beta
is between Tier one all the zeros lie on
the unit circle okay so they prove that
this this interior of the disk is zero
free region so is the exterior of a disk
and one so this
theorem is one of the oldest in this
areas proved many decades ago and one
very cool story that that's been going
on is that now there's a there's a
computational exploration of this
phenomenon started by work of ravinok
and others which says that well you know
this these zeros correspond to phase
transitions but they also tell us where
we can approximate like on a computer
the polynomial efficiently so for
example there's a line of work showing
that you can approximate the partition
function of using metal model
efficiently that is in polynomial time
away from the sorry quasi-polynomial
time away from the zeros again this has
this boils down to the fact that the
logarithm of the partition function has
a rapidly converging power series inside
the zero for each okay so so that's all
I want to say about the easing model
those are those are the two things I
wanted to say and roughly you know what
was the summary of the talk well you can
encode all this data all this
interesting combinatorial data and
polynomials which then have these three
interfaces of how to access some
coefficient zeros and their function
values and in general you can't do
anything right all polynomials is an
incredibly rich like wild set of objects
you can't you can't expect to have nice
relationships between these things but
if you know something about existence of
a nice zero free region usually a convex
cone and perhaps something about
concavity of log on that region then you
can easily move between these three
representations and you can get nice
theorems and algorithms out of it so I
guess I'm already over time so I'll just
end with the slide listing their
connections to many other areas that are
people are working on intensity in the
program that I didn't discuss and one
question is we have all these arrows
which of these can you actually
implement in polynomial time so the exam
remember I have to fake that polynomial
because I couldn't compute it there's a
good reason for that
I couldn't do it in polynomial time and
so there algorithmic questions there as
well
[Applause]
questions I don't think everything goes
away so there's a definition of
analogous to this real stability for
analytic functions not having zeros in
the upper half plane a lot of the
properties that of this being preserved
under various linear operators that also
holds I don't think it's been explored
from this combinatorial perspective
usually because we're used to dealing
with finite objects but it's a good
question I mean I think it's a very good
question
yeah so so okay so what I really mean is
usually in practice these polynomials
are they're np-hard or sharply hard to
approximate to compute exactly so we're
always working with approximations and
so once you only have approximations
these questions become very different
you can't just do interpolation or
something like that
plus they're usually have many variables
so anyway you would need you would need
many points to do interpolation so
really the the question is when you
restrict your attention to these special
families so you get some nice
computational features out of it I don't
know if Cheyenne wants to say more about
that
yep
yeah so yeah so so you're right so I I
what I did was with the expected
polynomial right your question is what
about the expected maximum route well
let's go back to this example right so
this this this says that with high
probability
you know the queue for this is 1 right
so the in particular the expectation is
1 so the expected maximum route can
that's the point the expected maximum
route can be horrible but the maximum
root of the expectation somehow cancels
out do that events
[Applause]
[Music]